[Música]
escuchar los primeros segundos de una
canción tu cerebro busca entre las
memorias más profundas puede reconocer
la letra el artista la melodía
o incluso el momento de tu vida en el
cual tú hayas escuchado que tal si
hacemos el experimento
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
con él
[Música]
porque al parecer no conocen la canción
no vi nadie siguiendo nuestros pasos
bueno al parecer la teoría no funciona
con ustedes pero pero no hay problema
vamos a probar con otra canción a ver si
es así la reconoce
vamos agarrando la onda no
bueno al parecer es así la reconocieron
verdad
bueno felicitaciones ya no son tan
jóvenes como pensaba
nos llevan a vivir que es la canción
anterior si existe es una canción muy
actual solo que aún no estaba en su
memoria bueno así como la música cambia
y evoluciona entre los distintos tiempos
hay algunas que perduran y es que estos
grandes artistas como queen lograron
cautivar a más de una generación hoy
podemos decir que la generación z o sea
nosotros disfrutamos de estos grandes
artistas también podemos decir que quinn
es nuestra banda de señores y señoras
hoy estamos aquí generaciones distintas
unas x detrás de otros govern homs pero
como un diagrama de bien como una
intersección
y hoy vamos a tratar de definir esta
intersección que no solo en internet
podemos encontrar una amplia discusión
sobre lo que nuestra generación
representa o nos dicen que somos los
individualistas los poco tolerables a la
frustración que nos estresamos de todo y
lo que normalmente escuchamos es que
solo pasamos en internet otros dicen que
somos la generación que más lee y aquí
tiene la mayor posibilidad del
intercambio de información la generación
que piensa crítica y globalmente somos
la generación de los locos creativos que
nacimos con un chip que nos permite ser
autodidactas y autosuficientes
tenemos una gran conciencia y
responsabilidad social y buscamos
generar cambios en el mundo ahora bien
lo que nosotros pensamos dos miembros de
esta generación es que nosotros vemos
más allá de las fronteras siempre
queremos emitir una opinión y participar
activamente en todo aquello que nos
gusta y nos deja alguna enseñanza
también buscamos el cambio para el
bienestar de la sociedad y del planeta
pero viendo nuestras habilidades y
trabajando colaborativamente nosotros al
contrario de lo que muchos piensan no
utilizamos el internet de manera poco
productiva sino que
una herramienta de muchas otras que
existen para poder cumplir nuestros
objetivos nosotros no pensábamos que
somos más inteligentes que las otras
generaciones al contrario estamos
convencidos que somos el reflejo de las
generaciones pasadas adaptadas en un
tiempo actual y descubrimos cómo estas
generaciones en diferentes tiempos y con
diferentes tecnologías se plantearon el
mismo reto de nosotros cambiar vidas un
claro ejemplo de esto es nuestro valor
el en su época y con su tecnología se
dispuso a hacer la primera guía de
turismo de todo el ecuador a nosotros
nos llena de emoción y de alegría
escucharle mi abuelita hablar sobre sus
historias como el viajaba por ecuador
compartiendo con la gente viviendo su
cultura y como él también fracasó la
gente no creyó en él pero se supo
levantar y nos enorgullece saber que
ahora nosotros estamos haciendo lo que
él hacía hace más de 30 años
nos dimos cuenta que con gorra y pudimos
desconocer y de redescubrir el ecuador
de aprender de las experiencias de la
gente de vivir nuevas experiencias por
parte de nosotros nos dimos cuenta que
no hay una generación mejor que otra que
no hay mejores personas que otras
podemos aprender de las experiencias de
las personas y del camino recorrido por
las otras generaciones con alegría hemos
visto como personas que se desenvuelven
en distintos ámbitos ecuatorianos y de
otros países nos han sabido dar una mano
y ahora podemos decir que tenemos
hermanos en diferentes partes del mundo
que están caminando con nosotros
training estuvo presidente
implícitamente a lo largo de nuestra
vida estuvo desde pequeño con los
cuentos que nos contaban acerca de mi
abuelo estuvo presente ya más grandes en
nuestro grupo de teatro en nuestro grupo
de baile con rain y es del producto de
estar orgullosos de nuestras raíces de
ser ecuatorianos y de lo que significa
acción nosotros quisimos descubrir ese
país que nosotros soñábamos quisimos
conocer más sobre su cultura sus
tradiciones vivir al máximo en este país
con nuevas experiencias de raimi nos
permitió poner en juego nuestro
liderazgo para encontrar personas
dispuestas a crear una economía
responsable colaborativa y sostenible
que ayude a los sectores más pequeños
del turismo y los incluyen las
plataformas digitales
jaime es el producto de todo lo que
hemos venido caminando a lo largo de
nuestra vida nos permitió comenzar algo
nuevo empieza con un viaje inesperado
con razones poco lógicas que nosotros no
acabamos de entender pero siempre estuvo
inherente a lo largo de nuestras vidas
nos mostró como las generaciones cuando
se unen pueden trabajar juntas y
trabajar mejor
pat es una palabra en inglés significa
camino y es un acrónimo que trata de
definir esta intersección
pero personas las personas a las que
ayudamos las personas que nos ayudan
todas las personas que se atraviesan en
nuestro camino las que creen en ti y las
que se unen las que se arriesgan contigo
a mi amor amor como el único motor de
capa capaz de cambiar algún amor como la
conceptualización de la razón de los
movimientos sociales amor como lo que
atraviesa fronteras diferencias de
edades y gustos musicales amor como lo
que sentimos nosotros amor de hermanos
bebé tiempo tiempo como el mejor regalo
que un ser humano puede dar tiempo como
la mejor prueba de fe que te pueden
brindar tiempo como la certeza de que
mientras pasamos por el mundo vamos
dejando vuelta
haciendo lo que hagamos
de hermandad al igual que pone tu hombre
que no tiene miedo de arriesgar
y esto no tiene que discutir contigo de
lo que no tienen en criticar y el que se
acerca a ti sin ninguna máscara pop es
un estilo de vida una forma de vida no
sólo nuestra no sólo de nuestra
generación es la estilo de vida la
filosofía de vida de muchos hombres y
mujeres a quienes les gusta ayudar estas
cuatro palabras en el orden que tú
quieras ponerlas pueden ser la guía de
tu vida puede ser la que te corrige la
que te levanta la que como la brújula
del capitán jack sparrow marca lo que
más amas lo que más deseas porque hay
que liderar para cambiar emprender para
ayudar innovar para construir
ahora mientras nosotros atravesamos el
valle de la muerte de gorra y me hemos
ido construyendo nuestro path se sigue
formando desde pequeños hasta era que
asumimos nuestro rol como activistas
sociales que plantean un pacto social
pierdas en el camino capten nuevas ideas
porque es de ustedes de valientes y
lograr regresar porque no siempre es
malo perder pero hay que aprender a
regresar así que pierdan en el camino
pierdan se percaten nuevas ideas
reflexionen mediten y regresen mejorados
con un nuevo espíritu
porque como al ver alguien alguna vez
nos dijo hay que ser valientes para
salir al mundo porque en el mundo hay un
millón de ideas y tú puedes agarrar esas
ideas porque no arriesga no gana
pat es nuestra filosofía y es a la vez
esa intersección que buscábamos definir
y que hoy nos une a las diferentes
generaciones y hoy también puede ser
suya muchas gracias
[Aplausos]